what's going on man what's happening how
are you next minute you okay why I love
you shoes thank you I love yours Oh real
old or not these came out in 2016 okay
compliment 200 that's like the custodial
engineer but you're like at a high level
you're not like pushing the car you're
like you're white-collar they really
should be so it's not clean quality or
male nurse shoe they are yeah yeah male
nurse look in the male nurse clown you
have like multicolor what kind of
sneakers of those Adi does oh god yes my
son said well shopping somewhere that I
shouldn't have been probably like a
Barney's or some fancy place and he's
like oh dad those are really cool you
should get those and I'm like hmm
they look like for you there yeah
they're there every color of the rainbow
fuzzy they're like oh yeah they're made
out of like carpet material yeah it's
really something will you buy something
will you buy something that you might
necessarily like just because like your
son says it's cool and you're like
everyone wants their son to kind of
think they're cool would you why would
you buy stuff that you wouldn't normally
yes I did which was this I mean I like a
shoe I like a comfortable tennis shoe
and they're comfortable it gives me
something to talk about on the radio and
you you shop at Barneys would your fans
it's it's really weird how fans expect
like the musicians or whatever it is to
be a certain way with your fans be
surprised at some of the places you go
for your clothes like we thought he was
shopping at Target I've been known to
shop at RJ you have tar say yeah
fantastic yeah I don't I don't I just go
wherever doesn't know I don't know like
exclusive although I do have a shopper
yeah person shop do you have a personal
shop what does impersonal shallow people
have them show pair it should be yeah
it's a sure everything is French in it
right no you know that's just no I know
one bothers me I only people that bother
many people want to come out to me and
say I think you're so funny you just say
I loved you and elf and all that
those are the only things that give
exact an elephant access or campaign
hoarding events and and and and and
airports it really those are kind of the
places where I get it that's the time
know emboss I go anywhere I want I have
to tell you like it's like you know I
mean I'm sure you've gotten this a
million times but like I'm talking a
chatroom that's Jim right there he's
pointy I wish that were you handsome Rob
handsome handsome Rob ugly salmon
mediocre Jim like when you said I've
seen it in photos I portaling a lot of
equipment yeah I got the gig equipment
he sure does that's why he's handsome
absolutely kids all dick yeah when you
says a handsome dick though the shirt in
New York is they're dancin dick Manitoba
works here of course he does you didn't
know the kiss of legend yeah yeah what
kind of meow radio like Bono
Oh ready buddy was like in a band a
great band yeah yeah anyway and he owned
a club for a while the the the
resemblance that you have to Will
Ferrell now that I'm seeing you in
person I don't know what you're talking
it's goddamn uncanny it gets the
craziest thing I ever saw in my life not
true when did you realize like when did
the confusion start when did Will
Ferrell when did Will Ferrell get famous
enough that you started getting mistaken
for Will Ferrell God well I don't want
to dwell on this too long it's really
sensitive I'm gonna get really mad yeah
okay I thought you guys were cool right
and [ __ ] cool shoes and stuff see you
and we'll foul on TV together right by
the way but you know the same clothes so
people just gonna make the mistake you
should dress different that was a
mistake
that was Jimmy Fallon mistake wardrobe
error when did it wind it will forget
I'll tell you with my one first meeting
with Will Ferrell's store and then we're
not gonna talk about any man ever again
ever
shan't he was in a he was on SNL and he
was in a film called he had a bit part
in a movie called ladies men sure the
ladies meant the Courvoisier then yeah
that guy it was one of those offshoots
from one of those skits it wasn't so
funny it wasn't right boo
he was terrible right yeah no you're
right anyway he's in a bunch of us and
all people are in it and at the time I
was dating this woman that worked for
the Paramount and there's a screening
and and you go to these things where
they show the film to the cast and
people that work for it and to get
excited and AAA and I go not knowing
that he would be there and at the time I
was getting a little bit this is
probably 2000 2001 and he was on SNL and
you know he was well Furness and he
wasn't the big community and movie star
at this point but I was getting it a
little bit you know he can't look like
dick time oh yeah really okay
anyway films over you go and you they
have you know buffet spreads and you can
go get your food and go eat and sit down
and I'm I see him standing over by the
shrimp and I'm like I'm not gonna go up
to the guy hey man you know people
telling you that so I go and I'm getting
my chicken skewers and there's a guy in
between us and then Will's over there I
think it was the shrimp or the crab legs
he went to expensive stuff and as we
have both have our plates of food we
turn and the gentleman that's between us
walks away and we both turn to each
other and I kind of look at him and he
looks at me and I gotta give it to him
he kind of looks at me up and down and
he goes you're very handsome
[Laughter]
so later on you know years later we see
each other and the whole thing he goes I
don't remember that you're really funny
but anyway yeah that you know he did the
whole thing of there's no welfare oh
there's only Chad Smith and I challenged
him to drum off you don't see how good
of a drummer you are and you got your
thing and we raised a lot of money and
turned into some weird viral thing I
thought this would put it to rest
dan Kay no nothing it's only it only
made it worse only yeah in the ass yeah
[ __ ] you will feel that's right yeah you
get sick of it I use not handle that
well you but you don't get I mean
people think they're really fun hey will
you know got it first one to do that
that's really original now you know you
take just goofy two guys that kind of
look like each other it's just whole
thing and whatever I mean obviously we
made a something out of it and and and
because of the Tonight Show and but you
know you were talking about shopping
with your son and him like telling you
to buy shoes they're cool and stuff does
he does he realize that like you're cool
like that he doesn't really think I'm
cool like my oldest son who's now 12 but
when I got the shoes I don't remember it
was probably five years ago but now he
kind of geek he gets it you know but he
doesn't I don't think he thinks I'm cool
the all the only thing that a couple
years ago
I did I played the drums to the theme
the Batman lego movie theme that's cool
and I was cool with him for about two
minutes this is funny in the car with my
bros do you buddy physically like
drummers always seem to break down
because it's just a grueling way to make
a living like the shoulders or the arms
you've any problems I'm a perfect
healthy specimen I'd say so by looking
at a wool jacket with no that's a rock
sure that's a rock that's right yeah no
good happy those guys yeah yeah a jacket
with no you are yeah all the dudes
around here psyched man exactly what
they wanted Chad Chad not wearing a
shirt with a suit that's a rockstar
thing in jakers I take up this morning
and I travel from LA yesterday to my kid
I didn't bring a shirt for my suit
that's the truth shoes but you're like I
can pull this off though but I'm like
alright I'll just go for the buttoned up
thing and yeah anyway Smith you know
yeah yeah yeah it's a fashion statement
no I don't
I've been marble whatever this is sure
granite plastic plastic yeah more like
cheap and SiriusXM it's not expensive
they don't have a lot of money they Wow
they have it they don't smoke yeah yeah
they keep it thank you yeah yeah you
know I've been fortunate that that I
have not had any serious drum related
injuries I've crashed on my motorcycle
and done stuff and baseball broken arms
and stuff but no you know and and and do
and you know I'm a physical drummer and
and it's not a natural motion to hit
things thousands of time really hard and
swing your arms around and whatnot so
yeah it's really prevented I just do
more preventative stuff like there's
inflammation and I don't get to thinking
about it but we have a guy that comes
out with us and it's like it's kinda
it's like a football team it's kind of a
you know we're in there with our ice
packs and stretching and and you know
I'd exercise a little bit but yeah it's
uh but it's also I found the older days
you get them I can use it or lose it
thing if I stop playing for a while it's
it's that's not necessarily really good
are you anything tonight you joined the
Navy right you got those guys in 88 the
Chili Peppers yes I joined 1980 how long
were they in existence before you joined
they started in 1983 okay and so they
were already five years together yeah it
was just a thing for an audition and you
went or did you know one of them nope
yep first okay yep I didn't know them I
had moved from California I'm sorry from
Detroit Michigan where I grew up and I
moved in August and the December is a
friend of a friend thing and where
they're looking for a drummer and I
wasn't like a big fan of the band or
anything I was like oh yeah the guys
with the socks or the dicks yeah they
got a record deal I'll try out for ya be
great and here we are right now you're
one of the socks on your dick I would
never do that
it's ridiculous yeah you do any photo
shoots like that if they did yes it was
like Spin Magazine when there was Spin
Magazine anymore
back then there was a you know
publication you want to show you in and
yeah I joined a band we start rehearsing
right away we're writing songs and then
all we got to do this summer swimsuit
issue or something for spin magnet
magazine okay and of course they had us
with socks on her dicks like on the
rocks in Malibu somewhere and I'm
looking around and I'm gone I think I'm
in the band now I think this is it
I got my uniform yeah yeah it's a rite
of passage who's the who's idea was that
somebody tells me that over there
Anthony Kiedis the one who pushed all
this because he's in good shape and he's
probably hey let's put socks on our dick
let's just show everything about our
dick I'm guessing all this is his idea
cuz he's in good shoes I want to show up
how I got a pulse
look at my pecs yeah but do you know how
that came into it just since then what
kind of being a big this sock thing will
just be naked everywhere everywhere I
just love being nude they love me
because I don't wear shirts right I have
no underwear on I can't do that some
comfortable no suit but I think it's a
it's for one thing to o'the way we
perform is very physical and and and so
you get a hot and it's easy you know
clothing-optional sure but that started
a long time ago and I think the sock
thing was I think a long time ago before
I joined the band played like us which I
think it was a strip club in Hollywood
like the cat club or something I can't
remember the name of the Pussycat Club
something and so key they kind of wanted
to outdo their strippers so to speak a
little bit and and and I think that's
where the sock was born hmm yeah you
guys needed to show more skin yeah yeah
yeah you just did what's the James
Corden the guy you just did the story of
the backseat the car karaoke dude how
come two of you have shirts on that and
hey two of you are nude that's really
what he's obsessed with talking about it
you mentioned the sock thing I didn't
always been thinking that but you
mention
so now you got me on this hole suck on a
[ __ ] thing we have to finish we have to
finish right he said it was only halfway
there but to address that you want what
happened huh what happened I don't know
Gordon who wants to see that guy without
a shirt yeah a nice name and James is
naked yeah I don't know maybe that day
well Josh I know Josh our guitarist
who's on the right he's Lee he has like
seven layers of clothes on we take our
shirts off and actually give it to him
ah he was mine our clothes that way you
don't lose them yeah I don't know I
think it was a contractual thing but
that makes sense yeah I love the gym why
aren't you I don't know guys get to take
their shirts off well now that we're
talking about it how often do the socks
fall off that should be but how do they
keep them on I mean mine stay on
obviously all right this is the last no
and we have no way we ever brought up
well Farrell since we brought it's only
now [ __ ] I'm leaving
you have to stuff your balls into the
side that's what holds it mom oh it does
yeah they'll be nerve-wracking no do you
wear them on sets too if you have do a
sex scene you have to were like a soccer
but that's like a special you know we
were supposed to talk about this after
after he said the balls thing oh you're
not supposed to talk about the socks
we're not doing it anymore no more
soccer or a Chad no more soccer coach
I've got new you're under control
let's go home tonight used to get is you
get a nice little aesthetic tube sock
stick your balls and your dick in it and
dance around and see if it stays on okay
I am Monday and that's just a regular
Monday night for you of course good is
there ever any like when the band
because the band's changed their sound
throughout the years obviously is every
good band does they evolve but I'm
always curious when bands do that if
there's like arguments amongst the
members of what that what this should
sound like because it sounds different
and this is gonna now sound like that
like need like how do you guys determine
that oh that's that's not a preconceived
like thing like oh we're gonna sound
like this now or something like that
that's just a
organic natural evolvement of like you
say bands change and hopefully they did
I think it's important as a band of
change and grow as creatively so yeah
it's just what you're into what we're
all into at the time you play and hear
what you like and what you don't like we
make suggestions all right how about
this and what do you think about that
and more like this and less like timing
normal stuff to us but we've been
together so long I think it's really
important to change and grow and come up
with new sounds and new things that
you're interested in and integrate that
into your thing and you know I would say
the biggest change for us lately I mean
obviously with Josh Klinghoffer joining
our band and being the guitar player as
a huge voice in our in our band but also
having Danger Mouse to our last record
yeah in the production side sonically
that was definitely a different sound
and we wrote in the studio which is
different for us but all those things we
want to keep moving forward and
challenging ourselves to grow when you
go back a few years and you have and
give it away becomes the hit that it
became is there it was pretty big hit
okay a lot of people liked it they do we
play actually at the end of our concert
people like it and you're performing
tonight by the way i start interrupt you
with a Landmarks live in concert oh it's
Friday at 10 o'clock sorry I plug my
show that's right I'm not just gonna
talk about Dixon Will Ferrell minutes in
you weren't supposed to bring them
outside yeah you did but yes landmark
live in concert Friday at 10 Lin Marx
Lin Marxist are back alive the Foo
Fighters yeah yeah the Foo Fighters at
the Acropolis in Athens Greece how about
that that's amazing it is amazing so
here's my question before we get there
okay
is there ever a consideration to be like
oh that like that that like kind of
rapping singing thing like everybody's
obsessed with that right now because
that song just came out are you guys
like oh my god we want to keep having
hits like this we should just do that
all the time because bands do that right
they make these terrible mistakes yeah
where they get influenced by the one
hint and you try to do a follow up and
it's just terrible you guys never
you guys were always smart enough to not
I'm shaking my head shaking his head no
shaking man that's good what he said
yeah yeah no no I mean you did it why do
it right I mean and cuz money that's why
people do it again yeah because that's
why I would do it again yeah but it's
never as good you can't I mean unless
you have beetles or something maybe but
even that you know I don't know I yeah
it's like no you would you would do it
twice Jim I would do nothing right away
I would do nothing until they literally
rang the cloth and it didn't change for
when they let it go yeah I certainly
married you know what no don't
it's single and Confused now but how
tempting is that like you're obviously
you're in a band that's known for like I
just sexuality how hard is it to be
faithful F maybe now it's easy but when
I first start like years ago it's got to
be different wasn't good at it you
weren't right no did you get caught yes
how did you get caught
phone blackberries remember when you
could pin on the blackberry it was a pin
like you could do the secret baby mmm
yeah or whatever it was like yeah that's
what she did she see something on your
phone did you send the wrong thing no
she saw it on my phone I [ __ ] up to it
happens I'm okay and I'm still married
if I was a real scumbag Jim's got a
great story about how he got caught
texting I really I know it might be a
bad I don't want to say well I'll just
say I just hit the wrong button I was
trying to look at it and I'm not kiddin
today it was a seven page PDF every
detail of PDF and my girlfriend went to
the computer to get something out she
was taking a college class at the time
and my [ __ ] she brought my PDF seven
page thing into she's like I didn't mean
to and it's like holy so when she
brought this over to do when you read
she didn't show up the up sure she did
Jim Jim with a gun she won't be up like
that but I get how it happens
standing over him Jim's going to carry
her she got so mad she's like your
little [ __ ] lol's and your emojis
when you mate look what people know like
women I think women accept that [ __ ] a
little better than men would like you
know she knows like all right look he's
a rock star whenever he [ __ ] up
I think women handle that a little bit
better than we would if it was in
Reverse I think they're a little more
willing to forgive and move on if you
promise to change your ways then I would
be okay I'll go back in you know yeah
and and yeah I mean but you have to
change your way yes or throw out the
printer or stop printing yeah do you
have that you have text banners come up
or did you learn like I did oh you turn
those [ __ ] things off you mean
they're like preview in 2005 I turned
those off you know you know like the
whole safari history
oh yeah private browsing my friend
Gonski that private browsing window is
not there for mistake that's for a
reason I took me a while to get on board
with that thing yeah we can watch some
porn all the time were you a wizard yes
what are you a mind